Good morning church.
Uh, my name is Brandon
and I get to serve here in the student ministry.
Uh, if you are new here, uh, I might be the first
to say welcome.
We're so glad you're here.
Uh, there is a new here section out in the lobby
that we would love for you guys to go to
'cause we wanna meet you and we have people who are
ready and willing.
Uh, if you're not new here
and you've been around for a while
and you're ready to take a next step, we have a class called
Next Steps, um,
kicks off next Sunday at 9:00 AM in Room 1 0 4.
It's a five week class designed to help you just learn
who we are as a church, what we believe,
how you can be involved, and just all the things.
There's no sign up required. So just show up and join us.
It'll be a great time. Um,
but if you're new here, if you're not new here, I want
to remind you that we have been studying Second Samuel, uh,
the series of the Promise King.
So let's turn our attention there.
We'll be in Second Samuel chapter 15
and 16 this morning, second Samuel 15
and 16.
These past few weeks we have seen the promise King David
himself fall in really big ways
and we've seen the ripple effects
that it has had on him and his family.
So we're gonna show the graphic here
to kinda show where we're at.
We're in, we're in between the 13 and 19.
And so David's personal troubles, uh,
things are getting hard, uh, for him.
But today in the midst of all the ripple effects,
in the midst of all the suffering, in the midst
of all the trials, we see David
discover his dependence on the Lord
in very real ways.
We see David return to a place that he's very familiar
with the wilderness.
Now it isn't by choice that David goes to the wilderness.
He's not on a vacation per se,
but it is a decision that is made for him
because an enemy is on the rise
and an enemy is coming after him.
And this isn't a foreign nation,
these aren't the Philistines, it's his own son who is coming
after him and is coming for the throne.
And I also wanna preface that this is a heavy text.
There are things that we will see that we will struggle
to wrap our heads around.
But also, not only is this a heavy text,
but some of you are walking through heavy seasons.
Some of you guys may feel like you are in the wilderness.
Some of you may be suffering right now as we speak.
So my encouragement for us as we look at this text
and as we look at our own lives is to zoom out
and see the bigger picture.
This is not just a story
of a son revolting against his father for the throne.
This story fits inside of a much bigger story that fits
inside of a much bigger story.
And so the bigger story that we see here is
that God restores.
And we see that in our text in uh, 15 through 16.
'cause 15 and 16 is something really cool.
They have this really cool bookend
of God fulfilling his promise of judgment on David.
But in the middle of that, we see our main idea.
We see the hope that we have.
We see God in his grace, restoring, we see God in His grace
bringing David back.
But let's pray. Let's pray and ask the Lord to show us
and to help us as we go.
Lord, would you or would you open our eyes?
Would you open our hearts
and ears to see who you are through your word?
God, would you make us more holy?
Would you make us look more like Christ each and every day?
God, would you use everything to restore us,
to make us depend on you?
In your name we pray. Amen.
So I mentioned how chapter 15 and 16 have this book in.
Well, what I mean by that, well, the theme
that we say at the beginning of 15 is the same theme
that we see at the end of 16.
So what is the theme?
We see God's judgment on David
through Absalon.
We see God's judgments on David through Absalon.
Let's first provide some context on why David is even
being judged.
Oh, we saw a couple weeks ago when second Samuel 11 though,
while all of David's men were out at battle,
David remained in Jerusalem.
It is there where he saw a woman named Bathsheba
who had a husband named Uriah and the Lord
and David Hughes the position that the Lord had given him
to take Bathsheba.
And he doesn't stop there
because when things become very real for David,
he doesn't repent right away.
But he again uses the position God has put him in
to take out Uriah to cover up his sin.
And God's word tells us
that these actions displeased the Lord.
But the Lord wasn't just displeased and moved on.
No, the Lord raised up someone named Nathan to go to David
to confront him and to tell him what was to come
because of his sin.
So because of David's sin with Bathsheba,
we see this in two Samuel 12, 11 through 14,
thus says the Lord
behold I will raise the evil against you out
of your own house and I will take your wives
before your eyes and give them to your neighbor
and he shall take your wives in the sight of the sun
for you did it secretly.
But I will do this thing. Before all Israel and
before the sun, David said to Nathan,
I have sinned against the Lord.
And Nathan said to David,
the Lord also has put away your sin.
You shall not die nevertheless be God nevertheless.
Because by this deed you have utterly scorned the Lord.
The child who is born to you shall die.
God's judgment on David is a result of David's sin.
And in our text when we're reading it, we need that.
We need that to be very clear.
Because as hard as the things we see in this text, we need
to understand that it is not without reason.
David's sin. David fell
and this is the judgment to starting in chapter 15
will read verses one through 12.
So after this, Absalon got himself a chariot in horses
and 50 men to run before him.
And Absalon used to rise early
and stand beside the way of the gates.
And when any man had a dispute to come
before the king for judgments, absalon would call to him
and say, from what city are you?
And when he said, your servant is of such
and such tribe in Israel, Epsilon would say to him, see,
your claims are good and right,
but there is no man designated by the king to hear you.
Then Absalon would say, oh, that I were judged in the land
and every man was a dispute or Cause might come to me
and I would give him justice.
Whenever a man came near to pay homage to him,
he would put out his hand and take hold of him and kiss him.
Thus Absalon did to all of Israel who had come
to the king for judgment.
So Absalon stole the hearts of the men of Israel.
At the end of the, at the end of four years, Absalon said
to the king, please let me go pay my vow, which I have vowed
to the Lord and he wrong for your servant, vow
to vow while I lived de ashore
and a Abraham saying, if the Lord will indeed bring me back
to Jerusalem, then I will offer worship to the Lord.
The king said to him, go in peace.
So he rose and went to,
but Absalon sent secret messengers throughout all the tribes
of Israel saying, as soon as you hear the sign
of the trumpet, then say, Absalon is king as Heon.
When Absalon went, 200 men
with absalon went 200 men from Jerusalem
who were invited guests and they went in their innocence
and knew nothing.
And while Absalon was offering sacrifices, he sent
for a HIA fell the Gileadite,
David's counselor from his city Galo.
And the conspiracy grew strong
and the people with absalon kept increasing.
So who is Absalon and why is he revolting against the king?
Well, we learned last week that Absalon is one
of David's sons.
And more recently they haven't had the best relationship.
It all started when Epsilon's sister, which happens
to also be happens to also be one of David's daughters,
was violated by another one of David's sons, which then led
to Absalon taking matters into his own hands
and to kill his half-brother.
So because of this Absalon then flees the Gesu
and lives there for three years away from his family,
away from his home, away from David.
Eventually Absalon is then brought back to Jerusalem,
but he's not allowed to be with the king
and his presence for two whole years.
And in that time we see bitterness grow inside
of him against the king.
And on top of that bitterness, there is already a sense
of aggression in him.
All that boiling up now leads to what we are seeing unfold.
So we see David has sinned against a holy God
and sin has consequences.
And Nathan said that the consequence is
that evil would rise out of his own house.
We see that unfolding. Was David's sin forgiven?
Yes. But did that sin still need to be dealt with?
Yes. Absalon, David's son is simply serving as an agent
or an instrument of God's judgments.
He's making himself to be king.
He's, he's getting these chariots, uh, and these horses
and he's running, having them run in front of him.
He's standing outside
of the gate just stopping people on their way
and he's using his smooth speech to convince them
and persuade them to turn against David.
And last week we saw
that there was no one more handsome than Absalon.
And so the people were easily won over.
He was saying things, oh, if only I were in charge,
if only I were the king,
then just then you would get the judgment
that you're looking for.
Oh, I'm, I'm sorry that the king can't meet with you.
He's busy with other matters or he isn't feeling well
and says, well this is why I should be king.
I I'm available, I'm here. I can give you what you want.
But not only is he deceiving the people,
he goes a step further to deceive David.
He says, oh king, if you will, will you let your servant go
and pay my vow to the Lord?
I made a promise to him that if he ever brought me back
that I would, I would pay offerings
and worship to him there.
But he's lying because we know that when Absalon got back
to Jerusalem, he burns down Joe Abs field
because he wouldn't talk to him.
This is all a plot to overthrow David.
We see this in verse 10 again.
But Absalon sent secret messengers throughout
all the tribes of Israel.
As soon as you hear the child of the trumpet, then say,
Absalon is king.
And the people who were won over
by abson kept growing and growing.
And this becomes a problem for King David.
But the hard part is, is that the problems don't stop there.
Remember how I said it bookend. So in the beginning we see
God's judgment on David through Abson,
but we also see it at the ends.
Turn with me to chapter 16 verse 15.
As we see God's judgment unfold
starting in verse 15.
Now Absalom and all the people, the men of Israel came
to Jerusalem and a HiTA fell with them, with him
and hue the arch archive.
David's friend came to Absalon Hue, said to Absalon,
long live the king, long live the king.
And Absalon said to hue, is this your,
is this your loyalty to your friends?
Why did you not go with your friends who she said
to Absalon, no for whom the Lord and his people
and all the men of Israel have chosen his I will be
and with him I will remain and again, whom should I serve?
Should it not be his son as I serves your father,
so I will serve you.
Then Absalon said to Hitha fell,
give your counsel, what shall we do?
Hitha fell, said to Absalon, take your father's concubine
to whom he has left to keep the house.
And all Israel we hear that you have made yourself a stench
to your father in the hands of all who are
with you will be strengthened.
So they pitched the 10 for Absalon on the roof
and Absalon took his father's concubines in the sight
of all Israel.
Now in those days, the Council of Hitha fell,
gave was if one consulted the word of God.
So was all the council of Hitha fell, esteemed both by David
and by Absalon.
Very disturbing scene we see here.
But like I said at the very beginning, we must zoom out
to see what the Lord is doing through it.
God's judgment on David through Absalom.
And we can find comfort in the fact
that God is not in the business
of sweeping sins under the rug.
God is not in the business of playing favorites.
God sees all sin, even the sin of King David
that he did in private.
But not only does God see all sin,
but God as a thorough judge, there must be a judgment
for all sin, even our sin today.
But if we just look at the judgment,
then we would miss what's happening in the middle.
We would miss what the Lord is doing through this 'cause.
We see that through judgments, David is
restored through judgments.
David is restored. This is the main idea.
This is what we find in the middle of what God is doing.
Restoration,
rediscovery, realignment.
And so we're gonna jump around
and see how all that unfolds for David.
But before, since there's a lot
of scripture, I do want to set the scene.
So we saw in 15 at the beginning, the Absalon has come up
with this plan to overthrow the king.
David eventually hears about this
and he flees les's, they overtake them and David
and his men go towards the wilderness.
And if you're familiar with David back in one Samuel,
we know that the wilderness is his bread and butter.
The wilderness is his home court advantage.
It's his paycom center with the best fans in the world
because in one Samuel we saw
in the wilderness the Lord Hughes that time it's
where David has grown the most.
It's where he writes these psalms.
It's where he depends on the Lord in very real ways.
It's where he becomes the king the Lord wants him to be.
But just because it's the place that he's familiar
with doesn't make it any less difficult.
It is still a hard season for David.
So we're gonna see a lot of pain
and a lot of heartache unfold for him.
Like I said, we're gonna pull out these moments
where we see the Lord really working in his heart
and drawing him closer to him.
So where do we say, let's start in chapter 15, verse 19
and 20, chapter 15, 19 and 20.
This says as they're leaving Jerusalem,
then the king said the itai, the gi.
Why do you also go with us? Go back and stay with the king.
For you are a foreigner and also in exile from your home.
You came only yesterday in July.
Today make you wander about with us
since I go, I know not where.
Go back and take your brothers with you
and may the Lord show steadfast love
and faithfulness to you.
So David is fleeing because an army is invading his home
and potentially the army will come after him here soon.
And so it makes the most sense to keep them around
for protection.
But instead David is looking out for the welfare of others.
Not only that, but he is also pointing these
foreigners to Yahweh.
In the middle of everything going on, he's looking to
and calling on Yahweh's steadfast love and faithfulness.
There is fear running through him.
His family is broken, he's out of control,
he is confused,
but yet he is hoping in the love
and faithfulness of the Lord, the love
that he has been shown time and time again.
Here we see David is demonstrating selflessness and hope.
Jump down with me to verses 24 to 26.
And AAR came up
and behold Zadak came also with all the Levites
bearing the arc of the covenant of God
and they sat down the ark of God
until the people had all passed out of this city
and the king said, Zadak carry the ark
of God back into the city.
If I find favor in the eyes of the Lord,
he will bring me back and let me see both it
and his dwelling place.
But if he says, I have no pleasure in you, behold here I am.
Let him do to me what seems good to him
as David is leaving Jerusalem, the priests wanna make sure
that he's protected, make sure the arc stays with him
and wouldn't it make sense for David
to want the arc there with him?
But here's where we see more connections to one Samuel,
back in one Samuel four,
before we ever met David
where the main characters were Samuel Eli
and his sons, Israel was in a battle with the Philistines
and they were losing this battle.
So all the leaders of Israel had this idea,
let's go grab the ark and maybe then we'll win the battle.
Let's, let's use the Lord as something to Hughes
for our protection, this genie in the bottle
that we can whip out
whenever the problem is, like I said, they were viewing God
as something to just be something to Hughes.
And so they end up losing the battle
and the arc is captured by the Philistines.
And so there's a similar situation here with David
where there is an enemy attacking him
where he does need help.
But instead of treating God as something to Hughes,
he trusts in God and his faithfulness.
David trusts that if it is the Lord's desire for him
to be back in Jerusalem, nothing can stop that.
But if it is the Lord's desire for him to spend the rest
of his days and the wilderness, nothing can stop that.
Here we see David demonstrating his trust
and dependence on the Lord's faithfulness.
Let's keep moving in verse 30 through 31.
But David went up the ascent of the amount of olives
weeping as he went barefoot and with his head covered
and all the people who were with him covered their heads
and they went up weeping as they went.
And it was told David, a hitha fell is
among the conspirators with Absalon.
And David said, oh Lord, please turn the council
of a hitha fell into foolishness.
David is weeping and journeying through the wilderness.
There is no hiding how hard this is for him.
And on top of that he hears
that someone he trusted his counselor a HIPA fell is now
among those rising against him.
And how does he respond?
Well we see the first thing he does is turn to the Lord.
He keeps his eyes fixated on the Lord.
He calls on the name of the Lord.
Not only is he crying real tears,
he's also crying out to God.
We see he's worshiping in the wilderness
and the Lord is kind
and he actually gives us a glimpse into
what David is praying.
David writes Psalm three
as he is in the wilderness fleeing from absalon.
So as we read Psalm three together, just
keep in mind all the things that he's going through
and the ways he is praying to the Lord.
Psalm three, Psalm of David when he fled from Absalon,
his son, oh Lord,
how many are my foes?
Many are rising against me, many are saying
of my soul there is no salvation for him
and God sayah
but you, oh Lord are a shield about me,
my glory and the lifter of my head.
I cried aloud to the Lord
and he answered me from his holy hill.
Sayah, I lay down and slept.
I woke again for the Lord sustained me.
I will not be afraid of many thousands of people
who have set themselves against me all around arise.
Oh Lord, save me.
Oh my God for you strike all my enemies on the cheek,
you break the teeth of the wicked
salvation belongs to the Lord.
Your blessing beyond your people.
These are the words of someone who is walking through
a difficult situation
but their eyes fully fixed on the Lord.
These are the words of someone who is being restored
in powerful ways.
These are the words of someone who believes
that God's purpose in all things is to bring restoration.
And I wanna pause from the story for just a second
and ask, do you believe that?
Do you trust in God when things are going south?
Are the challenges of life drawing you closer to the Lord
or further away from the Lord?
What is your response in the wilderness?
And I want to be clear that not all
suffering is because of sin.
Like in David's case, we live in a fallen broken world
where bad things happen or we will walk through trials.
But does our dependence in the Lord grow in those seasons?
Do we grow more selfish or do we grow more selfless?
Do we grow more hopeful or do we grow hopeless?
Do we try to play God and remain in control
and maybe even grow bitter with God through these seasons?
Do we take matters into our own hands?
Because we see in chapter 16, starting in verse 11,
David had a chance to take matters into his own hands.
We see there was a man from the house of Saul who saw David
and his companions and he cursed them.
He called David a worthless man.
He threw stones at David,
he threw dust at David.
And one of David's servants asked David, Hey,
can I go take care of this?
Here's how David responds in verse 11 and 12.
And David, David said to Abha
and to all his servants, behold,
my own son seeks my life.
How much more now this Benjamin Knight leave him alone
and let him curse for the Lord has told him to.
It may be that the Lord will look on the wrong done to me,
but the Lord will repay me with good for his cursing.
Today, David is surrendering.
David is saying not my will,
but yours, David knows that control, independence
and pride is what got him in this situation the first place.
And now he's fully surrendering everything over to the Lord.
He is rediscovering his dependence.
But like I said, not all suffering is a result of something
that needs to be said over and over again.
But can we still learn from David's situation? Yes.
'cause as hard as this season was for David, we have
to see the work the Lord is doing in his life.
And as hard as this season is for you right now,
my encouragement just like with this text, is to zoom out
and to see and to hope for what the Lord may be doing.
Because God is in the business of using
the hardest circumstances
to bring about the greatest restoration.
God is in the business of using the hardest things in life
to bring about the greatest restoration,
the greatest growth.
And if we look to the cross,
we see the clearest picture of that.
The cross shows us that Jesus took on God's judgments
so that we could be restored.
Jesus, who is God in the flesh,
took on the father's judgment so that we could be restored.
The cross is where we see judgments
and restoration go hand in hand.
But the one who died on the cross was not the one who needed
to be restored.
The one who died on the cross had no sin.
The one who died on the cross did nothing to displease
God the Father.
He lived the perfect life.
He fulfilled everything perfectly so
that we could be.
He was mocked, he was beaten, he was spa on.
He was stripped of his flows and he was crucified.
He took on judgment so that we wouldn't have to.
But not only has he has he taken on our judgment,
God's word promises that he will put on righteousness
to all those who will believe.
Second Corinthians 5 21.
For our sake, he made him
to be sin who knew no sin.
So that in him we might become the righteousness of God.
The hardest circumstance of God in the flesh, dying of death
that he did not deserve,
brought about the greatest restoration
that we could ever imagine.
Our greatest need has been met
because of Jesus, satisfying the wrath of God,
because of Jesus.
We never have to taste death
because he took it all on himself.
And that gift, that eternal life, that salvation,
that righteousness is offered to all those
who would acknowledge it, they have sins,
maybe not in the same ways as David,
but against the same holy God.
And that sin is worthy of judgment.
That sin has caused a separation between us and the Father.
But if you turn to Jesus, the one
who took on God's judgment, you will be saved.
One thing we have seen in Second Samuel recently is
that God takes sin seriously
and sin will be dealt with
for those who have put their faith in Jesus.
Our hope is that our sin has already been taken care of.
We stand assured.
But for those who have not put their faith in Jesus,
God will judge sin just like we saw
with David.
But if you have trusted in the Lord through Jesus,
what are the implications of this?
What are we to do?
Well, if judgment has been satisfied
and we have been restored, where does that leave us?
Well, the Father still wants to make us holy.
The Father wants to draw us closer to him.
And God as a loving father wants his children
to share in his holiness.
God wants us to look more and more like Christ every day.
And so if we just look at David's situation,
we look at the cross and we can conclude that
he Hughes the hardest circumstances
to bring about the greatest restoration,
then we should prepare ourselves with the fact
that the Lord may hug the situation like he did in David's
life to bring us closer to him.
Once again, it's not always because someone has sinned, but
because we live in a fallen world
and the hope that we have is that God can use all things
to bring restoration.
And so some of you in here have probably lost among close
to you this past year.
Some of you in here might have lost your
job this past year.
Some of you in here know someone
or yourself are experiencing health issues
and concerns that you would've never dreamt of.
Some of you in here are having a relationship conflict
and familial conflict.
And the truth is, some of you in here may be going
through something so hard
that you wish you were going through what David went through.
'cause it seems more manageable in all of these.
Our hope is in the fact that our father in heaven
who loves us will use all these things in powerful ways.
He will use all these things that draw us closer to him.
Hebrews 12 puts it best verses seven through 11.
It is for discipline
or training that you have to endure.
God is treating you as sons for
what son is there whom his father does not discipline.
If you are left without discipline
in which all have participated,
then you are illegitimate children and not sons.
Besides this, we have had early fathers who disciplined us
and we respected them, shall we not much more be subject
to the father of spirits
and live for they disciplined us for a short time,
as is the best to them,
but he disciplines us for our good
that we may share His holiness.
For the moment, all discipline seems painful
rather than pleasant.
But later it yields the peaceful fruit of righteousness
to those who have been trained by it.
It is painful. There's no hiding that fact.
You may be in an immense amount of pain right now,
but the hope is that it's not for nothing.
That the Lord is using it.
The Lord is using it to make us more righteous.
So endure through the encouragement
that the Lord is at work.
If anyone's ever had surgery, you can relate to the pain
of surgery and recovery.
But the joy of having bones back where they should be,
God's training, God's discipline, seasons of wilderness are
for us to grow and share in holiness.
But how are we to face these things?
Three steps we can do today in this week.
The first one can ask ourselves the question,
how is God using this situation in my life
to make me more like Jesus?
How is God using this situation in my life to make me more
like Jesus?
'cause if we look at David's life,
you know he was in the palace, started to drift
going to the wilderness.
The Lord is drawing him back to him, drawing him
in powerful ways.
So how's the Lord using the situation in your life
to make you more like Jesus?
The second thing we can do,
and this one is really done well in community,
we can remind ourselves how faithful God has been
and put our hope in the fact that he will continue
to be faithful.
We can remind ourselves
to the times God has been faithful in how he will continue
to be faithful.
And the last thing we can do is we,
as we even look at Psalm three as an example,
we can worship in the wilderness.
We can worship in the wilderness.
Things kept going from bad to worse.
For David turns to the Lord, prays
to the Lord, cries out to the Lord.
Writes Psalm three, celebrating the fact that the Lord
is the lifter of his head.
The Lord is his glory.
The Lord is his sustainer Through it all.
He didn't wait until he got back to Jerusalem.
He wrote those things in the wilderness
through everything he was going through.
But we need help to do that is only by God's grace,
but we can respond that way.
And so let's pray and ask for God to bring about
more restoration in our lives as we walk through all things.
Lord, would you help us God?
Would you be our sustainer? Would you be our confidence?
Would you be the lifter of our head? Would you be our glory?
God? Would you surround us?
Lord, there are so many stories in this room right now
of hard things but also of good things of Lord,
how you have used so many things.
God, the Bible tells us that God, that
you use the hardest things
to bring about the greatest restoration,
but it's hard to believe at times to God, would you help us
or would you surround us with people who will encourage us
when it's hard, when it doesn't make sense?
And then we pray, would you stand as we continue
to worship together?